เฮ
[Música]
Olá, pessoal, tudo bem? Tivemos um
probleminha aqui. Eu não sei se eu tô
conseguindo transmitir.
Eh, tá tendo algum problema aqui de
transmissão no Instagram. Não estou
conseguindo transmitir
também no Instagram.
Boa noite, Clari Leone. Boa noite a
todos que estão entrando na live. Eu vou
fazer o seguinte, eu vou desistir de
transmitir
no Instagram porque não sei porque tá
congelando aqui.
Tentar mais uma vez aqui.
Se eu não conseguir, vou desistir.
Bem, pessoal, tô meio confuso aqui, não
sei se tá ainda com Instagram, eu acho
que não tá.
Deixa eu ver se tá aparecendo aqui.
Não,
não tá aparecendo. Bem, vamos lá. Vamos
perder mais tempo. Não,
temos 37 pessoas ao vivo. Boa noite,
Rosana. Boa noite, Emily.
Ana Maria.
Eliseu, Maria Helena, Marcos, Lira.
Pessoal, vocês estão me ouvindo bem?
Como é que está o áudio? Me dê a
confirmação do áudio, tá?
Primeiramente, eu queria desejar a vocês
feliz dia dos namorados, porque hoje,
né? Espero que vocês possam aproveitar
esse dia, essa noite. Não recomendo ir
para restaurante porque fica sempre
muito cheio nessa data, né? Mas espero
que vocês estejam aí com seus entes
queridos.
Então, hoje eu quero bater um papo com
vocês sobre um assunto que tá dando
muito que falar nas redes sociais nos
últimos meses, né, e também nos
consultórios, que é o famoso ômega-3 e
que apareceu estudos aí falando mal do
ômega-3, né?
Mas antes eu gostaria de falar para
vocês que nós temos um grupo de
apoiadores, é a parte do canal fechado
que eu faço lives semanais exclusivas,
eu também respondo todas as dúvidas, tá?
Por mais complexas que sejam, nós já
temos esse grupo de apoiadores tem mais
de 2 anos. Então, se você tiver
condições de pagar o equivalente a um
café com pão de queijo por mês para ter
minha atenção semanal, clique no link
abaixo, né, no YouTube, no link Seja
membro.
E além disso, você tem acesso a um grupo
de eh no WhatsApp de pessoas
extremamente estudiosas, inteligentes,
interessantes, que discutem sobre
diversos assuntos e também tem acesso a
um documento com vários conteúdos
exclusivos que valem muito mais do que a
contribuição semanal. Outra coisa que eu
queria pedir para vocês é que escrevam
aqui nos comentários de onde vocês são.
Deem o seu alô. Isso é importante,
inclusive para colocar depois que o
vídeo sair do ao vivo, né, dos
comentários do YouTube. É muito
importante pro canal. E também mande as
suas dúvidas ao vivo. Depois de eu falar
aí por uns 20 minutos, eu vou responder
as dúvidas a respeito aí do ômega-3, OK?
Então, eu vou aqui conversar com vocês
sobre
esse assunto tão polêmico.
São 20 minutos de exposição e 20 minutos
de dúvidas, tá? Se tiver muita pergunta,
eu vou me concentrar somente nas dúvidas
relativas ao assunto de hoje, pra gente
também não estender demais essa live.
Sabe aquela história do ômega-3 faz bem
pro coração? Pois é, tem muita gente
questionando isso, vários estudos aí
sendo talvez mal interpretados. Tem um
pega ali que eu preciso explicar
direitinho para vocês. E olha, esse
assunto é mais interessante do que você
imagina, porque envolve um conceito de
estatística que eu mesmo não conhecia
bem e que mudou completamente a maneira
como a gente entende essa suplementação.
Deixa eu ver. Vocês estão me ouvindo
bem, né? áudio ótimo e vídeo também
ótimo. Vamos continuar então aqui.
Então, antes de começar eu quero que
vocês saibam que essa live surgiu de uma
pergunta que eu recebi várias vezes ao
longo das últimas semanas. Pacientes
chegando aqui no consultório confusos.
Doutor, eu vi na internet que ômega-3
causa arretmia, será que faz mal? E
agora eu faço o quê? Então essa confusão
tem fundamento, pessoal, porque
realmente existem estudos mostrando que
ômega-3 pode causar arritmia, mas também
existe estudos mostrando que ele salva
vidas. Então, como é que a gente
concilia isso, né? Como é que pode isso
então, né? Parece confuso. Então, pega
uma água, pega um cafezinho, senta aí
confortavelmente
no seu sofá, na sua poltrona, vamos
conversar como se você estivesse aqui na
minha sala. Eu vou explicar tudo
mastigadinho e no final vocês vão
entender porque que essa aparente
contradição, na verdade faz todo
sentido, ok?
Então, primeiro vamos deixar claro, o
ômega-3 realmente funciona, pessoal, não
é papo furado. Tem uma pancada de estudo
mostrando isso. Olha só, tem uma
metaanálise gigantesca. Eu estou falando
de mais de 120.000 pessoas acompanhadas
por anos e que mostrou uns resultados
bem impressionantes. O ômega-3 ele
reduziu em 28% o risco de infarto.
Pessoal, isso não é brincadeira. Quase
1/3 a menos de chance de ter um evento
cardiovascular. Para vocês terem uma
ideia do que isso significa, se numa
população de 1000 pessoas 100 teriam
infarto, com ômega-3 apenas 72 teriam.
Então são 28 vidas salvas a cada 1000
pessoas. diminui também em 19% os
eventos coronarianos maiores. É coisa
séria mesmo e não para por aí. Esse
danado baixa triglices, que é uma
beleza. Então, estamos falando aí de 25
a 30% de redução para quem tem
triglicerides ou triglicerídios nas
alturas. Então, trata-se de um santo
remédio. Então, eu lembro de um paciente
meu que chegou aqui no consultório com
triglice de 800 ng por m. 800.
O sujeito praticamente tinha mel
correndo nas veas. Então, depois de 3s
meses ômega-3 bem dosado baixou para
280. Ainda não era o ideal, mas que
diferença, não foi? Então, mecanismo de
ação do ômega-3 é fascinante. Ele tem
dois principais componentes, como muitos
de vocês já sabem, é o EPA e o DHA. são
siglas, significa
e cosa pentenoico e docosa exenoico. O
EPA ele funciona como guardião das
células do coração. Ele mantém aquela
pelinha, aquela camadinha interna do
endotélio que reverte, reveste as
artérias por dentro, funcionando de
maneira redonda. É tipo deixar o
encanamento da casa bem oleado, OK?
Então, sem ferrugem e sem entupimento.
Então, o EPA é bom para artéria de modo
geral e o DHA mais para sistema nervoso
de modo geral. Então, DHA tem esse papel
aí de ajudar os neurônios. Esse
componente faz uma faxina neurológica
que vocês não têm ideia. Estudos mostram
que pode ajudar a prevenir várias
doenças degenerativas, como Alzheimer,
melhorar a memória, a concentração, é
alimento pros neurônios. E tem mais,
ômega-3, ele é um anti-inflamatório e
não é um antiinflamatório fraco. Ele
compete com omega 6, que a gente em
geral consome em excesso.
E essa competição com omega 6 vai causar
uma redução de produção de substâncias
inflamatórias, tá? Então é uma gangue do
bem, né? Os ômega-3 brigando com a
gangue do mal dentro das nossas células.
Mas vamos ao plot dessa história, o lado
sombrio do ômega-3 aí, pelo menos nesses
estudos que surgiram nos últimos meses.
Agora chegou a parte que deixa todo
mundo de cabelo em pé. Então, estudos
recentes, e quando eu digo recente, é
coisa de 2024, mostraram que o ômega-3
pode aumentar o risco de fibrilação
atrial. E não é pouquinho, né? Estamos
falando aí em torno de 25 a 49%
de aumento. Mas calma, antes de vocês
saírem jogando fora os ôga3 de casa,
deixa explicar essa parte de maneira bem
explicadinha. Primeiro vamos entender o
que que é fibrilação atrial. É quando o
coração ele bate meio descompassado,
meio desorganizado, tipo uma banda
desafinada.
Então isso não é fatal. Na maioria das
vezes não é fatal, mas aumenta o risco
de AVC e pode dar uma sensação ruim no
peito. E a coisa funciona assim, quanto
maior a dose, maior o risco. Doses altas
acima de 4 g por dia praticamente
dobraram o risco de arritmia. Então
pacientes que tomaram mais de 1 g por
dia apresentaram risco, segundo esses
estudos, 49% maior desenvolver
fibrilação atrial. doses intermediárias,
tipo 1,8 g aumentaram em 84%.
Não sei que os números assustam, mas eu
vou explicar essa contradição, vocês vão
entender.
As doses padrão, que seria 840 mg por
dia, não dariam problema aparente. Então
vocês já viram aqueles remédios que em
dose baixa curam, em dose alta poderiam
causar problema. Então ômega-3 seria
meio assim. Eu não concordo com isso, já
vou explicar porque que deu esses
resultados, tá? O mecanismo é meio
contraditório, né? Então ele
estabilizaria as membranas do coração,
né? O ômega-3, mas ao mesmo tempo ele
mexeria com os canais de cálcio, só
potássio. Isso poderia dar problema.
Então, mas eu quero deixar claro, eu não
concordo com muitas das conclusões
desses estudos. Eu vou apresentar para
vocês aqui uma explicação clara do
porquê desses achados contraditórios,
porque que eles acontecem. Então, segura
um pouco a ponta aí que eu já falo desse
assunto, OK? Então, existiria também uma
possível associação entre altos níveis
de ômega-3 e aumento do risco de câncer
de próstata. Perol, não é para entrar em
pânico, tá? É bom saber que existe esses
estudos também. Eu acho que estudos que
tiveram problemas estatísticos, doses
muito altas por muito tempo poderiam
também reduzir a função do sistema
imune. O corpo ficaria meio preguiçoso
para reagir às infecções. De novo, eu
não concordo com isso. Eu acho que isso
não são problemas estatísticos, mas
vamos falar dos problemas um pouco mais
adiante.
Outro ponto importante, risco de
sangramento, mas esse risco só vale para
doses muito altas mesmo de ômega-3, tipo
seis ou mais cápsulas por dia. O EPA em
altas doses aumentaria em 50% o risco
relativo de sangramento. É um aumento
modesto, cerca de 0,6 se a gente for
falar de risco absoluto, mas quem toma
anticoagulante precisa ficar muito
atento quanto a isso. E tem mais, tem um
estudo chinês gigante que foi publicado
no British Medical Journal e acompanhou
mais de 415.000 pessoas por 12 anos. E o
resultado, para quem é saudável, o
ômega-3 poderia aumentar em 13% risco de
fibrilação atrial e 5% de AVC. Mas esa
aí, presta atenção nos detalhes. Isso
valeria para pessoas saudáveis. Para
quem já tem problema cardíaco, a
história muda completamente. Então,
nesse mesmo estudo gigante, pessoas que
já tinham doença cardiovascular tiveram
15% menos progressão da fibrilação trial
para imparo e 9% menos morte por
problemas cardíacos. Tá ficando confuso?
Eu peço desculpas por isso, eu entendo,
mas tem uma explicação muito elegante
para isso. Então, acompanha até o final
para você entender o que eu tô falando.
E aqui entra uma das maiores descobertas
da medicina moderna sobre como
interpretar dados científicos.
Antes de falar dos riscos competitivos,
eu preciso contar para vocês uma
história que vai explicar porque que os
estudos sobre ômega-3 são tão
contraditórios. É tipo um episódio do
CSI Médico, não sei se vocês conhecem
esse seriado americano aí de
investigação científica, né? Então eu
vou contar a história de dois estudos
gigantes que chegaram a conclusões
opostas. O primeiro chama-se reduce it e
o outro é o strength. Os dois tentaram,
desculpa, os dois testaram o ômega-3 em
milhares de pessoas, mais um deu
positivo e o outro deu negativo. E como
é que pode isso? Vou explicar.
O reduce, ele testou o EPA puro, né, o
Ecosa pentenoico, que é aquele do
coração, contra um placebo de óleo
mineral,
OK? Então, de um lado placebo, que seria
entre aspas píl de farinha, mas nesse
caso é óleo mineral, e de outro lado
EPA. Qual foi o resultado? Seria
fantástico, né? Esse estudo houve
redução de infarto de derrame no grupo
de ômega-3 em relação ao placebo com
óleo mineral. funcionou que é uma
beleza. Aí a galera comemorou eureca
ômega-3 funciona. Mas aí veio o outro
estudo strength que testou o EPA mais
DHA contra o placebo. Só que agora não é
mais óleo mineral, óleo de milho. E o
resultado? Nada, zero benefício. O
estudo foi até interrompido antes do
tempo porque não estava dando em nada.
Mas, pô, como assim pensar os
pesquisadores aí que descobriram o
problema. O placebo não era placebo.
Isso acontece muito. Estudo mais do que
você imagina. Então, no reducit, o
placebo de óleo mineral, ele causou um
estrago nos pacientes. Ele aumentou o
LDL colesterol em 10%,
a proteína ser reativa em 32%, a
polipoproteína B em quase 8%. Ou seja, o
placebo estava fazendo mal. Então não
era só o ômega-3 fazendo bem, era o
placebo fazendo mal também.
É como se você testasse um remédio
contra veneno. Claro que o remédio vai
parecer fantástico comparado ao veneno,
entendeu? Mas se você testar o mesmo
remédio contra água, aí a história muda.
Não sei se vocês captaram, mas tentei
simplificar o máximo possível. Então, no
estudo strength o placebo de óleo de
milho não fez mal nenhum. Aí o ômega-3
teve que mostrar o seu valor real sem
nenhum tipo de truque e nesse estudo não
teve benefício significativo.
Isso é só a ponta do iceberg dos
problemas metodológicos. Tem mais coisa
ainda. Muitos estudos usam ômega-3 velho
oxidado, que é tipo óleo de cozinha
velho. Ele não funciona direito. Então,
outros usam doses baixíssimas que nem
chegam a alterar os níveis de sangue. E
tem o viés, né, de publicação também.
Tem estudos que mostram malefício.
Esses estudos que são mais focados em
malefício, eles são publicados mais
facilmente que estudos positivos. Vocês
já ouviram falar daquela história que
notícia ruim vende muito mais? Então
vale nesse caso aqui outro problema, a
qualidade de suplementos.
Diferente de remédio, os suplementos não
passam pro controle tão rigoroso, né?
Então tem estudo mostrando que muitos
produtos de ômega-3 no mercado estão
oxidados, como já comentei, contaminados
ou com doses diferentes do que está no
rótulo. Aqui vem uma informação que pode
mudar tudo. O EPA isolado, ele pode
funcionar melhor que a combinação EPA e
DHA para questões cardíacas. Tem alguns
estudos mostrando isso. É como se fosse
dois remédios diferentes, né? O EPA
separado DHA e o EPA mais o DHA. OK?
Isso tem que ser confirmado por mais
estudos, mas alguns desses sugerem essa
questão. Agora que vocês entenderam
porque que os estudos são tão confusos,
eu vou explicar o conceito que realmente
mudou, como a gente interpreta tudo
isso, tá? aqui que a coisa fica
interessante de verdade. Tem um conceito
na estatística chamado riscos
competitivos
que explica essa aparente contradição do
ômega-3. Esse conceito ele é
revolucionário porque ele muda como é
que a gente interpreta os dados médicos.
Eu vou dar um exemplo bem prático para
vocês entenderem. Imaginem essa cena que
vocês têm duas formas de sair de cena,
ou seja, de vocês irem pro céu, OK? Ou
por infarto ou por arritmia. Então o
ômega-3 ele previne tanto o infarto que
as pessoas vivem tempo suficiente para
desenvolver arritmia. É tipo aquela
história, não morreu afogado, mas morreu
na praia. Então deixa eu contar uma
história real para ilustrar mais ainda
isso. Imagine dois grupos de 1000
pessoas cada um. No primeiro grupo, sem
ômega-3,
300 pessoas morrem de infarto aos 60
anos. No segundo grupo, ôega3, apenas
200 pessoas morrem de infarto aos 60
anos. OK?
Maravilha. Então, salvamos 100 vidas,
OK? Mas aquelas 100 pessoas que não
morreram aos 60 anos continuam vivendo,
OK? Óbvio, né? Não morreram, continuam
vivendo. Então, aos 75 anos, algumas
delas desenvolvem fibrilação atrial,
coisa que jamais teria acontecido se
elas tivessem morrido de infarto aos 60.
Então, quando você analisa só a
fibrilação arterial, parece que o
ômega-3 fez mal, mas na verdade ele fez
tão bem que permitiu que essas pessoas
vivessem tempo suficiente para poder ter
um problema mais na frente, menos grave.
Deu para entender? É como comparar duas
cidades. Em uma delas, as pessoas morrem
de acidente de trânsito aos 20 anos. Na
outra, elas vivem até os 80 e morrem de
câncer. Se você só olhar as estatísticas
de câncer, vai achar que a segunda
cidade é mais perigosa,
mas é óbvio que a segunda cidade é mais
saudável, né? Porque as pessoas
conseguiram viver até um ponto que elas
poderiam correr o risco de ter câncer.
Então, os estudos tradicionais usam uma
metodologia chamada Caplamer, que não
considera isso direito. Então, é como se
eles fossem contadores que só sabem
somar, mas não sabem interpretar o que
que os números significam. Então, quando
você usa a função de incidência
cumulativa, que é uma ferramenta
estatística mais sofisticada, que leva
em conta os riscos competitivos que eu
tô falando aqui, o cenário muda de
figura. Então, essa análise considera
que se você morreu de infarto, não pode
mais ter fibrilação atrial. Parece
óbvio, né? Mas muitos estudos acabam
ignorando isso na análise estatística.
Então, um dado interessante, a
fibrelação atrial, ela aumenta
exponencialmente com a idade. Então, a
cada década após 50 anos, o risco
praticamente dobra. Então, quando o
ômega-3 salva alguém de morrer de
infarto aos 60, essa pessoa vai
envelhecer e naturalmente vai ter o
maior risco de arritmia aos 70, 80, 90
anos.
A medicina moderna tem vários exemplos
disso. Por exemplo, nós conseguimos hoje
curar infecções que há mais de 100 anos
atrás matavam crianças, né? E o
resultado, essas crianças vão virar
adultas, crescem e hoje elas morrem de
câncer ou de outros problemas cardíacos
na velice. Então isso não significa que
os antibióticos são necessariamente
ruins, significa que eles funcionam tão
bem que permitiram que várias crianças
que não sobreviveram chegassem à idade
adulta, a idade também idosa e vivessem
o suficiente para ter outros problemas.
Então acho que ficou claro esse
conceito, certo? Então, qual que é a
pegada na prática? Agora que vocês
entenderam toda a complexidade, vou dar
as dicas reais de como usar o ômega-3 de
forma inteligente. Primeiro cenário,
pessoa saudável, querendo prevenir
problemas cardíacos, que é o caso da
maioria das pessoas que estão assistindo
esta live.
Aqui a estratégia é doses baixas, 250 a
500 mg de EPA mais DH combinados por
dia. Então a autoridade europeia de
segurança alimentar considera doses de
até 5 g seguras, mas para prevenção
muitas vezes menos é mais. Então
preferencialmente
dividido em duas tomadas. Então assim,
você pega os benefícios
anti-inflamatórios e de proteção
cardiovascular sem esse risco. E a
retimica, como eu tô dizendo, esse risco
não é real, ele é um risco fabricado
porque a pessoa viveu tempo suficiente
para desenvolver a arretmia. Então vamos
ao segundo cenário. Pessoas com
triglicides altos. Aí você pode usar
doses maiores, tipo 1 a 4 g por dia, mas
sempre com monitoramento cardíaco. Então
para triglicérides, o ômega-3 é eficaz,
ele ajuda a baixar. reduz de 25 a 30% e
é um dos poucos suplementos que
realmente funciona para isso. Tem outros
aí que tipo berberina, tipo
exonicotinato
ôega-3 é um dos stop.
Terceiro cenário, a pessoa que já teve
infarto ou tem doença coronariana já
documentada, estabelecida. Aqui o
benefício é muito maior que o risco de
suposta arritmia. Então, mesmo que
apareça essa arritmia, a redução de
morte pro problema coronário compensa
muito. Então, doses de 2 a 4 g
adequadas.
Em relação à qualidade, isso é crucial.
É a primeira regra, nem todo ômega-3 é
igual. A primeira regra, verifiquem se o
produto foi testado para contaminantes
como mercúrio, chumbo e dexinas. Então,
peixes grandes, tipo,
eh, atum, né, acumulam essas porcarias
aí. Então, tem várias marcas muito boas.
Eu vou comentar sobre algumas aqui. Eu
vou colocar na tela para vocês verem.
Eu particularmente sugiro Omega Per, né?
Omegaaper é uma das melhores marcas que
nós temos disponíveis, mas temos também
outras boas marcas. Nós temos a Nutri
Blue Omegac, óleo de crida pura vida,
tem o triple strength ômega da GNC,
ômega-3 triglicerides daia ultra ômega-3
da NAL Foods, ômega da Supranayak, ôega
for plus Vitafor. E se você quiser uma
fonte confiável para compra do
Omegaapure, eu vou deixar aqui o
contato, tá aí na tela, um telefone de
WhatsApp para vocês adquirirem.
Lembrando que é só uma sugestão, tem
todas as outras marcas que eu comentei
que também são top, estão estão aí na
sua tela e vocês sempre podem procurar
suas próprias fontes para compra online,
tá? Ou compra direta na loja. Então,
falamos já da primeira regra que é a
qualidade.
Vamos falar agora da segunda regra.
EPA isolado parece ser mais eficaz que
combinações de EPA e DH para benefícios
do coração, tá? tem o seu objetivo foi
coração, é interessante buscar produtos
com mais EPA, tá? Agora, se o objetivo
for melhorar a cognição cérebro, aí o
pensamento, o raciocínio, aí eu sugiro
produtos com concentração maior de DHA.
Terceira regra, a forma molecular
importa. O ômega-3 na forma de
fosfolipídios, como no caso do óleo de
crio, tem absorção melhor que na forma
de triglicerídeos. Então, busque na
forma de triglicerídeos e não decios
grassos livres, tá?
Então esse ômega-3 francamente é melhor.
É como comparar um remédio comum como um
remédio de liberação controlada. Quarta
regra, cuidado com a oxidação. Ômega-3
oxida fácil, especialmente se exposto à
luz, calor ou oxigênio. Se o produto tem
cheiro forte de peixe ou gosto ruim, tá
oxidado. Então, nesse caso, precisa
jogar fora. Até aquele teste você pode
fazer de colocar o ômega-3 no freezer ou
no congelador. Se ele formar cristais de
gelo, se ele congelar, é sinal de um
produto de má qualidade.
E uma dica interessante, sempre tome
ômega-3 com outras gorduras, né? Ômega-3
é uma gordura, elipossolúvel, então se
você ingerir mais gordura, vai ajudar na
absorção, vai ficar mais fácil de
absorver. Então eu recomendo tomar
sempre junto com uma refeição, nunca te
toma o vazio. Pode ser com um pedaço de
abacate, com castanhou ou até mesmo
junto com outras gorduras. Sobre o
tempo, time, não existe um horário
mágico, mas consistência é muito
importante. Então, se você escolher um
horário, mantém aquele horário. E é
melhor tomar todo dia no mesmo horário
para não esquecer, tá? E seu corpo
precisa manter níveis estáveis desses
ácios gráos aí do ômega-3. E uma
informação que pouca gente sabe, a
proporção ômega-3 para ômega6 é mais
importante que a quantidade absoluta de
ômega-3. As nossas dietas geralmente têm
uma proporção de 20 para um de ômega-6
para ômega-3. Então o ideal seria quatro
para um, né? Então isso tá bem longe da
realidade hoje das dietas. Então além de
aumentar ômega-3, é bom você diminuir os
óleos de sementes comuns ou até cortar.
Só utilizar esse tipo de óleo de maneira
indireta. Quando você não tiver escolha,
vai comer fora de casa. no restaurante,
aí você não vai escolher o óleo que foi
utilizado. Então, mas em casa use óleo
de coco, azeite de oliva para fazer uma
fritura rápida. Use até óleo de abacate
também
e corte o óleo de soja, o óleo de milho,
o óleo de girassol e o canola. E para e
para finalizar essa parte prática,
sempre façam exames regulares, façam com
apohamento médico, especialmente se
tiverem tomando doses mais altas, né?
minimamente um hemograma, um
coagulograma e um eletrocardiograma. E
isso não é paranoia, é prudência, tá? E
fontes alimentares continuam sendo
ideais, né? Sardinha, cavalinha, né?
Peixe cavalo ou cavalinha, salmão
selvagem, chuva, peixes pequenos do mar
ou peixes de criação que não tem um
problema de comer ração.
Uma porção de 100 g de cavalo ou
cavalinha tem 4580 mg de com DHA. É
bastante coisas, né? Então, duas porções
de peixe gordo por semana e vocês estão
bem servidos também, tá?
Então, antes da gente responder as
perguntas, o que que nós aprendemos?
Então vamos fazer aqui uma recapitulação
do que nós aprendemos. Primeiro, a
ciência é complexa, cheia de nuances. Eu
sei que isso é difícil para muitas
pessoas entenderem e confuso. Não
existem respostas simples para questões
complexas. O ômega-3 não é nem santo,
nem demônio. Ele é uma ferramenta
poderosa que tem que ser analisada com
calma, precisa ser usada com sabedoria e
conhecimento. Os estudos científicos
podem ser enganos se não entendermos a
metodologia. O caso, né, dos dois
estudos grandes que eu falei do reduc e
o strength nos ensinou que até o placebo
pode influenciar resultados. Isso nos
lembra de sempre questionar como é que
esse estudo foi feito. Terceiro, o
conceito de risco competitivo nos ensina
que às vezes um aparente problema pode
ser, na verdade, um sinal de sucesso
terapêutico. Então você viver mais, você
tá sujeito a mais risco, né? Isso que eu
falei durante a live.
Então, nós conseguimos evitar que as
pessoas morram de algum problema e agora
elas viveram tempo suficiente para ter
outros problemas. Isso não é falha, é
sucesso. Só que a estatística às vezes
não pega isso. O quarto ponto, a
qualidade importa mais do que
quantidade. Um ômega-3 bem dosado, não
oxidado, na forma correta, vale mais que
doses cavalares de produto ruim. E
quinto, individualização é a chave. Não
existe dose única que serve para todo
mundo. Seu contexto de saúde, seus
exames, seus fatores de risco, tudo
importa na decisão. Então, a mensagem
que eu quero deixar é: não saiam tomando
ômega-3 de maneira desordenada,
mas também não ten medo dele baseado em
alguma manchete sensacionalista.
A verdade está no meio como sempre e
precisa ser construída com conhecimento,
exames e acompanhamento adequado. E por
favor, pessoal, aquela conversa, cada um
fala uma coisa, cada um fala uma coisa.
Medicina não é matemática exata e nunca
vai ser, é arte e ciência juntas. Os
mesmos dados podem ter interpretações
diferentes, dependendo do contexto de
quem tá interpretando e dos vieses, né?
Inclusive, a metodologia usada é
fundamental,
então é complicado analisar artigo, não
é fácil não.
Ômega-3 nos ensina uma lição valiosa
sobre como devemos enxergar a medicina
moderna com ceticismo científico, mas
também com mente aberta pros benefícios
comprovados.
sempre questionando, sempre aprendendo.
Eu sei que hoje nós estamos numa época
de polarizações, as pessoas não querem
mais pensar, elas querem comprar um
pacote completo, mas eu não sou assim e
eu não vou ser intelectualmente
desonesto com vocês e ficar trazendo
informações aqui só para ficar na
torcida, tá pessoal? Bem, vamos às
perguntas.
Boa noite, Clari, Rosana, Emily,
Ana Maria,
obrigado pelo comentário aí.
Então, uma pergunta aqui do Eliseu, qual
é a quantidade mínima de ômega-3 a ser
consumida? Já respondi isso durante a
live,
tá? Já já foi a parte prática final que
eu falei, o Eliseu, tá? Só você voltar
na parte que eu falo das doses.
Boa noite, Marcos Lira, Maria Afonso,
Alexandre Arnaldo, Ski ou Sky.
Alimentos vegetais contém ômega-3 em
quantidades desprezíveis? Tem menos
ômega-3, tá? E geralmente não é o EPA,
nem o DHA, é o ácido linoleico. Então
você pode ingerir linhaça, você pode
gerir chia, vai ter ômega-3, mas a
conversão do organismo no EPA e no DH é
bem reduzida. Não que você não deva usar
linhas chia ou algo do tipo, mas entenda
que vai ter que comer muita quantidade e
o organismo não vai conseguir fazer a
conversão total, porque as enzimas que
fazem essa conversão delta saturasi,
elas estão em pequena quantidade.
Pessoal comentando o áudio tá bom.
H não afina tanto quanto na toquinase,
Eliseu. Geralmente não. Depende da
quantidade, obviamente, mas geralmente
se você for fazer comparações aí de
doses equivalentes, não é tão forte
quantoquinados.
Ó, vou mostrar de novo aqui, Ana Maria,
tá? As marcas,
certo?
Mais perguntas aqui. Parkinson,
bipolaridade, esquizofrina em autismo.
Ô3 ajuda em tudo isso. Não vai resolver
sozinho, obviamente, mas vai ajudar em
tudo isso que você tá falando aí.
Eliseu,
eu tomava 3 g diariamente, mas agora
estou com intolerância a estamina, então
tive que parar devido à coceira. Isso
pode ser uma coisa temporária, Emily.
Depois você vai conseguir tolerar quando
você tiver uma melhora aí da função
intestinal.
Boa noite, Valesca. Good night. Good
evening.
Opa, obrigado aí pela informação, Emily.
Ao consumir 4 g de ômega-3 por dia,
quanto tempo leva para obter os
benefícios cognitivos? Variável, Eliseu.
Variável, tá? Vamos colocar entre 4
semanas e 3 meses.
Qual é o nome do Astro Gráxa Omega3 que
é melhor que DH e EPA juntos? Não, não.
Esse daí não é bem isso não. O Eliseu,
muito obrigado pelo comentário, viu?
Não, se for feito frito com óleo
correto, não, não faz mal, tá? vai fazer
mal se você olhar óleo de soja, milho,
canola ou girassol, que são óleos que
oxidam muito fácil, que tem adição de
substâncias químicas e que também tem
a questão
de resíduos industriais.
Tem um endócton aqui que disse que
ômega-3, dependendo pode dar parada
cardíaca. Eu expliquei a questão do da
fibrilação, né? Eu acredito que você
tenha escutado, Ana. Se você não
escutou, depois veja o vídeo de novo,
tá? Depois que sair do ao vivo.
Quais efes colaterais para quem consumir
acima de 4 g por dia? Pode ter
sangramento, né? Pode ter aumento de
risco de fibrilação trial, eh eh pode
ter que mais? Como eu comentei, aumento
de risco de câncer de próstata por um
estudo, mas isso eu não tô muito
convencido não, tá?
Ah,
OK. M ali.
Aí a forma mais severa de arritmia. OK.
Então, o ômega-3 ajuda sim para quem eh
tem TDH, tá? Lógico que não vai ser
usado exclusivamente nesses casos,
tá? Eh, vai ter que ter vários outros
suplementos juntos. Boa noite, toda Ana
Paula.
Sim, Deus no salva. Concordo com você,
Nati. Não sei se essa é a marca, não
conheço a marca Nati, viu?
Com certeza, Valesca.
Então, Rosana, se você tiver questões
neurológicas de memória, tá valendo, tá?
Sim. Vitar fora, né? É uma das marcas
que eu tô mostrando aí na tela, né? É
uma das boas marcas.
É o último aqui, o item 11.
Sim, se você começar com frequência,
você pode até parar, evitar de usar o
omega3 suplemento. Concordo com você,
Ana.
Ela
veio em pó, em cápsulas. Achei estranho.
Tem que conversar com a famía, pode ser
que eles tenham colocado, impregnado o
pó com o ômega-3, tá? Banha de pouco é
muito polêmico, Ana, mas eu acho uma
gordura altamente aceitável. Não como
principal gordura, mas eu acho bem
aceitável. É uma gordura saturada que
foi demonizado de maneira incorreta pelo
ponto de vista.
Boa noite, Alice Fogel.
A ciência é um mercado quem paga manda.
Eu concordo. Realmente isso acontece
muito, viu?
Isso é um problema mesmo.
Qual o exame para saber? Existe exame
para ver ômega ômega-3 no sangue, tá?
Não é um exame de rotina,
mas existe. Tem que pagar do bolso
porque os planos de saúde não cobrem.
Obrigada, Dirlei, pela pelo comentário.
Sim, eu concordo com você. Já teve
várias denúncias aí de órgãos que
ã teve questão aí de conflito de
interesse com dinheiro.
Boa noite.
Sardinha e lata na água. É boa ideia?
Sim. Se você achar uma em azeite oliva,
melhor ainda.
Se estiver usando de culofenaco, pode
causar sangramento. Declofenaco, em si
não é um remédio que dá distúrboio de
coagulação, não, tá? Que dá mais é
anticoagulante e antiagregante.
Anticofenácinatório.
Tomou óleo de fígado de bacalhau e
cartilagem tubarão. Tem ômega-3 nesses
suplementos? Tem. Tem sim. Tá.
Ômega3, magnésio, vitamina D3, obquinol,
testosterona alta? Não, testosterona é
adequada, não alta.
São bons, são bons ativos, sim, Eliseu,
obrigado Alexandre pelo comentário.
Depende do salmão, né? Não é uma coisa
que seja consenso, não.
Ah, doutor, o que que o senhor diz da
banha? Eu acho a banha um óleo
totalmente aceitável para cozinhar, só
que existe muita polêmica, muita briga
ainda sobre as gorduras saturadas, mas
por via das dúvidas, prefiro óleo de
coco, o azeite de oliva e óleo de
abacate, tá? Mas eu não tenho nada
contra óleo de banha.
algum peixe rico em ômega que não seja
sardinha. Falei da cavala, né? A cavala
tem muito ômega-3, tá?
Eu uso banho e azeite. Perfeito.
Pra memória que ela tá usando.
DHA 500 mg naturales e de boa qualidade.
Eu conheço essa marca, tá? Não tá na
minha lista aqui porque
eu não fiz testes com ela ainda, mas não
tenho nada contra
sim. Hora de f bacalhau, como eu
comentei,
uso daia, né, que tá aqui na lista
está com Samina. É difícil para caramba
de tratar isso mesmo. Samira,
tutano de boi para fitura é bom. É, pode
utilizar, apesar de não ser muito
prático.
Ah, estou fazendo reposição hormonal
abidêntica endócrino. Passoumega ajuda
na menopausa? Sim, ajuda. Ah, mas tem
outros óleos que ajudam, né? Óleo de
borragem e óleo de prímola também
ajudam.
Eh, outros ômeas da pura vida são bons
também. Sim, é uma marca boa. Até que
teve aquela questão da compra pela
Nestlê, mas aparentemente não teve queda
de qualidade depois da compra.
Ã, por qual motivo? Somente o peixe de
fundo de oceano frio quando tem 3 em
boas quantidades? Não sei dizer. Eliseu,
boa pergunta. Eu sei que os peixes de de
águas geladas t bastante ôega-3. Agora,
a razão exata eu nunca pesquisei.
Obrigado, minha querida. Obrigado.
De nada.
No Trify é uma marca também que eu não
coloquei na lista aí, mas não tem
nenhuma informação negativa sobre
eh gestante tomar mega DHA ou EPA.
Boa pergunta. Nesse caso, eu sugeri o
mega dega por causa da formação do do
cérebro bebê.
Não, não existe isso de curar totalmente
a usá com 3. Isso aí não não procede.
Pessoal, então eu não quero me estender
demais nessa live. Já temos 40 minutos,
foram meia hora de exposição. Eu já
respondi todas as perguntas
e nós nos vemos na semana que vem com
uma próxima live. Eu vou deixar o
telefone caso vocês tenham interesse,
também na descrição e no meu comentário.
Um grande abraço, um beijo no coração de
vocês. Até a próxima.
M.